Senior Researcher Dr. Victor Stafford had
an obsession.
He was one of the SCP Foundation’s most
brilliant minds, but right now, that mind
was being twisted by grief and confusion.
One of his closest friends and confidantes
at the Foundation, an anomalous astrophysics
expert named Dr. Lilibeth Orion, had gone
missing.
Not killed, not kidnapped.
Truly disappeared without a trace.
Back when Dr. Orion first fell off the map,
Dr. Stafford had led the charge into the emergency
investigation.
It should come as a surprise to nobody that
employee turnaround at the SCP Foundation
is higher than perhaps any other organization
on Earth.
We’ve made whole videos about the various
ways unfortunate Foundation operatives might
die in the line of duty, but few things are
worse than never having the closure of knowing
what actually happened to your missing friend.
Dr. Orion had experienced a tragedy almost
a year before her mysterious disappearance.
Her husband and young daughter were both killed
in a car accident.
Naturally, rumors spread that perhaps the
grief had just gotten too much for the poor
doctor, but Dr. Stafford wouldn’t hear a
word of it.
Part of him knew that Lilibeth Orion was still
alive, out there, somewhere.
But he needed to discover exactly what had
happened to her.
This is what sparked the obsession that would
destroy his respectable Foundation career,
and perhaps even his mind.
He’d stepped beyond professional boundaries
by accessing a number of deeply personal documents,
including personnel files and Site-19 project
histories.
He read through reams of archival documentation
concerning unexplained disappearances of Foundation
personnel - including the disappearance of
05-7, several decades prior.
Dr. Stafford’s search went on for twenty
years, still finding very little, except an
arcane pattern of connection between each
of those who disappeared: All were Foundation
employees with three degrees of separation
from one another, to put it very reductively.
A huge number of disappearances, Dr. Lilibeth
Orion included.
He didn’t know what was taking them, or
why, but he would bet his life on the belief
there was one force behind it all.
And while Dr. Stafford had no real way of
knowing, he was indeed right.
Nearly twenty years prior, Dr. Orion found
herself in a strange and unfamiliar place
upon waking.
A year before that, she’d lived in a two-story
suburban home, but after the deaths of her
husband and child, she’d moved into an apartment
in the city.
That house just had too many empty spaces
in it for her.
But now she was neither in her old home nor
her new apartment: She was in a rustic, two-level
cottage, somewhere out in the countryside.
Naturally, Dr. Orion first tried calling for
help, but there was no cell phone signal and
no wifi.
After that, she tried fleeing the property
on foot, only to encounter its first anomalous
effect: Upon walking out of one edge of the
property, you simply reappear, entering the
other.
The house sat at the center of a half-mile
of grassy land, cordoned off with a wholesome
picket fence.
A lonely swing set sat near a tree in the
yard.
No matter how many times Dr. Orion tried to
run past the confines of the building’s
land, she would appear facing the rustic little
cottage once more.
Next, she started yelling and calling for
help.
Nothing.
Only birds and squirrels seemed to register
her cries, and they ran away in fear.
Nothing about the cottage suggested its location.
Was she even still in the United States anymore?
And the flat, distant, and uninhabited planes
stretching out beyond her only served to confirm
exactly what she feared: There would be nobody
out there to help her.
This would be a terrifying situation for anyone,
but thankfully, Dr. Orion’s Foundation training
allowed her to keep her cool under pressure.
She immediately switched into research and
investigation mode; perhaps there would be
some key to her escape or rescue elsewhere
in the cottage.
Knowledge is power, and Dr. Orion certainly
didn’t like feeling powerless.
The first and second floor of the cottage
felt relatively conventional: Furniture, knickknacks,
charming - but slightly peeled - wallpaper.
Nothing about it was overtly anomalous.
Soon, however, she detected a strange noise
coming from the attic.
Like the slow chugging of an old machine.
Upon climbing up there, she found a strange
contraption made from wood and metal sitting
in the corner of the attic, with a plaque
affixed to the front.
It also had several PVC pipes running out
of it and feeding into the wall, off into
an unknown location.
Dr. Orion approached and studied the plaque.
It read: “Please fill this machine once
per day at noontime.
We cannot arrive with as much haste if the
machine runs dry.
We hope you understand, and trust that you
will keep your side of the arrangement now
that we have kept ours.
Thank you.”
How strange.
She needed to investigate further.
Down in the basement, she found another more
anomalous element to the house: A large clump
of strange, unidentifiable vegetation.
It was largely a kind of murky green, with
notes of red and purple that made it seem
almost otherworldly.
Strangest of all, when in the plant’s proximity,
she heard an odd, static-like noise coming
off of it.
It also intermittently let off a strange,
red pulse.
It didn’t take long for Dr. Orion to intuit
that this pulse was actually morse code, delivering
two distinct messages on a loop.
The first was “Thanks for keeping the plants
fed.
Hit a snag in traffic, might take a bit longer
than expected.”, and the second was “Please
keep this hatch open only in good weather.
Please keep it closed for rain, snow, and
the chill of winter.
Thank you.”
Just as the message suggested, there was a
hatch in the ceiling up above, angled perfectly
to allow daylight to filter through onto the
alien vegetation whenever it was left open.
The last notable thing that Dr. Orion found
in the house was seemingly the least supernatural
of the three, and yet, the most anomalous
- in the traditional sense of the word.
It was a closed-network SCP Foundation computer
terminal and a rather old model at that.
She managed to boot it up and gain access
with her login credentials, but what she saw
definitely didn’t bring her any comfort.
She was currently trapped in the middle of
what the victims of this place call SCP-2508.
The first and most prescient piece of news
was that this little predicament Dr. Orion
found herself in was a life sentence.
Only one person would ever be trapped here
at a time, and they would remain here until
they died, one way or another.
All she could do in the meantime is work to
maintain the house, and hope that whoever
its owner was would someday return and give
her some respite.
That’s when she found a final note left
by O5-7.
It read…
“I was driving home when it happened.
It was about a 30 minute commute through a
lot of back roads, and I was terribly drunk.
It was one of those "XK Class Scenario averted,
let's celebrate" occasions, so I didn't really
hesitate to down more than my fair share of
wine.
When I arrived at my front porch, car askew
so that the front tires dug into the dirt
on my front lawn, I stumbled for the door.
After a great amount of fidgeting I managed
to get my key in the lock, and finally got
the door open.
But then when I looked around, it wasn't my
house at all.
It was this place.
Dumbfounded, I went back outside.
Surely, I thought, I had accidentally entered
another house in my drunken stupor.
But now not even the outside was as expected.
The suburban-urban environment had shifted
to a countryside.
My car was still there, sitting on the asphalt
road which was now a dirt road.
Everything was different, and it was never
quite the same.
That was all 23 years ago.
No doubt my position as O5 was replaced long,
long ago, and here I am, having found startlingly
few answers.
Every once in a while I'll find an old shoe
or a photograph of someone who came before
me, and I am reminded how we are all chained
together in an oblivious and obligatory service
to this place.
Lately the clouds keep rolling in, and the
plants in the basement are buzzing more than
usual.
I hear the gurgling of water draining through
the pipes in the walls from that old dusty
machine, and sometimes I try to find where
that water goes.
I think it goes out beyond the house, into
the grassy field in front of the swing set.
When I lay on the grass, sometimes, if I listen
very closely and everything else is quiet,
I swear I can hear noises coming from far
below the ground.
They sound like some kind of clockwork mechanism,
its gears quietly humming.
I don't know what it means, and I don't think
I ever will.
Undoubtedly, the most puzzling thing about
this place is really quite a small feature.
There's a computer terminal in the study,
and it looks like it's one of the oldest things
in the house.
It's clearly from the Foundation, but it's…
Unsettling, to say the least.
We would have known about this if the Foundation
knew, I'm sure.
But if that's truly the case, then it still
doesn't explain how the anomaly got its number
designation.
Is it arbitrary, or is it actually cataloged
in the outside world?
I don't think it's possible to know from here.
Sometimes I feel like I'm waiting for something,
or for someone.
It's not for someone to save me, but it's
as if I'm waiting to meet someone here.
I dream of what that meeting might be, or
why it might be in the first place.
But somewhere deep down I know that I will
almost certainly die here, and this long wait
will be passed down to another, to continue
waiting with bated breath for something, though
what exactly that something is we can't be
sure of.
Maybe someday I'll learn how the food gets
restocked.”
As she finished the note, Dr. Orion felt a
cold wave of dread wash over her.
She wasn’t just trapped: She was the latest
in a long line of trapped, doomed people who’d
been confined and then perished in this lonely
little cottage, keeping the place in shape
while someone or something made its long journey
back.
If this was anything to go by, chances are,
she wouldn’t be the last one to perish here
after decades of waiting.
As the months turned into years, and the years
turned into decades, Dr. Orion stuck it out.
She learned some things about the place, things
she assumed she might be able to pass on to
others.
Like the machine in the attic, the one that
needs water every day, is somehow tied to
both the integrity of the cottage itself and
its occupant.
If not properly watered, the occupant will
begin to grow sick, and eventually, start
to die.
Back on the outside, Dr. Victor Stafford was
finally disciplined for his extra-curricular
investigations.
He was stripped of all his titles and clearances
for spending all his time searching into the
mystery of Dr. Lilibeth Orion.
The Foundation frankly had more important
things to deal with.
They thought Stafford was crazy.
They had no idea how deep this mystery went,
about how many Foundation operatives were
taken, or most important of all: The fact
that Stafford knew who would be taken next.
Back in SCP-2508, things were different for
Dr. Orion.
Nearly twenty years had passed, and she was
in a different stage of her life.
To some extent, she’d come to terms with
her new reality.
When she dreamed of her old life, she would
often wonder whether those dreams were her
actual life, and her time in the cottage was
just a dark, recurring nightmare.
Maybe she’d die here someday, and let another
take her place.
Or maybe...She wouldn’t.
Dr. Orion, you see, was always the curious
type.
Even if she did die here, she’d never let
herself die without knowing what was really
happening at that strange little cottage.
And even more importantly: What was happening
under it...
Now go check out “The Horror of Body Stealing
Rain - SCP-3300” and “You'll NEVER Make
It To SCP-084 - Static Tower” for more frightening
anomalous places you’ll never escape!